and then
i want us to think about what it truly
means to become
human like the f zine and you asked me
about what motivated my meaning of life
symposium
what motivated it in part i mean of
course it was an inside joke of turning
but what motivated him in part was
actually a midlife crisis
so the joke that i always like to say is
christos papadimitriou a famous greek
professor
who was previously at mit at harvard at
stanford berkeley everywhere
uh brilliant brilliant person that's
actually costis
advisor yeah uh so so christopher mc3
likes to say
that when you're an undergrad you work
like a rat
to get into grad school and where you're
grasping you work like a rat
to get your phd and where you're a
postdoc you work like a rat
to get your assistant professors to jail
and where in this profession you work
like a rat
to become a full professor and then when
you're a full professor
well by then you're basically a rat
[Laughter]
that's brilliant so basically what
happened to me is that
i arrived at the end of the rat race
yeah you know
life is a rat race you constantly have
hurdles to jump over you constantly have
tunnels and secret pathways
and i figured it all out and eventually
as i was turning 42
i looked back and i was like wow that
was an awesome rat race
but i'm not a rat i basically got out of
the labyrinth and i was like
i'm not i'm not a rat turns out is that
the first moment where you saw
that it's that you were in a rat race it
no no no i've known that i'm in a rat
race for a long time it's so easy to be
in a rat race it's so easy to be an
undergrad
because you have problem sets and you
know we're all smart people
you know problem set it has a solution
somebody made it for you you can just
solve it
everything was made as a test and you
keep passing those tests and tests and
tests and tests
and you have tasks that are well defined
the phd is a little different
because it's more open-ended but yet you
have an advisor who's guiding you
and then you become a professor and
tenure
is a well said defined set of tasks and
you do all that
and at 42 i basically had bought a house
three kids beautiful wife tenure
yeah awesome students tons of grants
life was basically laid out for me and
that's when i had my
main life crisis that's when people
usually buy a harley davidson
and they basically say oh i need
something new i need something different
and to be young myself etc
but basically that was my realization
that it's not a rat race
that there's no rat race it's over that
i have to basically think how do i
fully instantiate myself how do i
complete my transformation into an
actual human
being because it's very easy to sort of
forget
all the intangibles of life it's very
hard to just sort of think about the
next task and the next ask and it's all
metrics and you know what's the number
of viewers i have what is the number of
you know publications i have what's the
number of citations
the number of talks the number of grants
it's very easy to quantify everything
and then at some point you're like this
is real life
it's not a test anymore and that's
something that i told my wife
early on i was like no no no
our life is not going to be let's put
the kids through college
and that you know maybe that's when i
escaped the rat race maybe it continued
being a rat race maybe the next step
would have been
all right how do i make sure that my kid
is first in class how do i make sure
that they're you know into the
great scholars and then you know they're
into college
and then you're like 60.
[Laughter]
so how do you how do you escape but what
is uh uh
is is there a light at the end of the
tunnel of a midlife crisis
so so you should watch that symposium
because the videos were transformative
to me
and to many others so basically the
advice that i received from all of my
friends
was so meaningful this you know there's
some some advice that basically says
you have to constantly maintain
unachievable goals goals that you can
make progress towards
but you can never be fully done with and
i think that's almost
playing into the sort of rat race thing
like basically make sure that there's
more obstacles for your little
rat persona to jump through
so that's one possibility so first of
all
watch is it available it's on youtube
just google it
google really meaning of life i've known
this and you should have told me this
like this is awesome
okay yeah this is great but and also
like
you know saying rat race is uh
you know if we look at ratatouille it's
not
i mean that's a beautiful that's a
beautiful thing
uh of of challenges and overcoming
childhood that could be
fundamentally the meaning of life is
uh to see life as a set of challenges
and to fully engage
in the overcoming of those challenges i
would say that that's embracing the rat
race view of life so so a joke that we
like to have with my wife all the time
is we basically say we we pretend that
we're in this all-inclusive resort
that we've basically hired all these
people to go on the esplanade and play
games because we enjoy watching people
playing on the esplanade and
we enjoy sort of laying and looking at
life and all the people biking and
rollerblading and all of that
and then we've paid all these people in
this all-inclusive resort that we live
in
and then uh what are we going to do
today i'm like oh i've signed up for
professor activities
it's going to be awesome they lined up a
bunch of super smart mit students for me
to meet with i'm going to have a grant
writing meeting afterwards it's going to
be
awesome and then she signed up for a
bunch of consulting activities it's
going to be great
and then in the evening we just get back
together and say hey how was your
consulting today so in a way that's
another view of life
of basically wait a minute if i was a
gazillionaire
what would i choose to do i would
probably pay an awesome university to
give me an office there
and just pay a bunch of super smart
people to work with me even though they
don't really want to
et cetera et cetera in fact i would have
exactly the life that i have now
working my bot off every single day
because it's so freaking fulfilling well
that's so let's clarify this is a
beautiful way it's almost like a video
game view of life that just a set of
i mean again game is not perhaps a
positive term but it's a
it's a it is a beautiful term so you
you do do you or do you not like the
rat race view of life no
because it is fulfilling in some right
place is about the goal
my view of life is about the path so
again
quote in greece those folks have to come
up with some good stuff
so this um odysseus elites basically
wrote
this uh beautiful poem about sort of
going through
uh life saying as you go through your
journey
impersonating ulysses of his voyage
he says wish that the path is long and
arduous
because when you get to ithaca
you might realize that it was all about
the path not the destination
and so the the rat review of life makes
it all about the destination it's
like how do i get through the maze to
get there
but the all-inclusive resort view of
life
is about the path it's about wow
today i couldn't wish for a better set
of activities
all programmed for me to enjoy
having my brain having my body having my
senses
and you know the life that i have it's a
very different kind of view
it's focused on the journey not on the
destination
you